ich weiß nicht wie sie das sehen meine
damen und herren aber ich persönlich
finde es richtig schade dass der mensch
keinen winterschlaf macht meine jetzt
wer wirklich der perfekte zeitpunkt oder
sich schön in irgendeiner höhle kuscheln
und irgendwann im märz wieder raus
kriechen stichwort corona wer weiß
vielleicht bringt ja auch unser
wellenbrecher lockdown endlich die wende
hier nochmal vom rbb einfach erklärt der
wellenbrecher shutdown auf englisch
circuit shutter und also kreislauf
unterbrecher soll funktionieren werden
überlastung schalter in einem stromkreis
es ist ein geplanter zeitlich begrenzter
lockdown mit dem ziel das
infektionsgeschehen wieder unter
kontrolle zu bringen
in der sache absolut richtig noch
schöner wäre es halt ohne den ganzen
sinnlosen grafik overkill und ohne die
bescheuerten geräusche meine meinung ja
danke reicht ja seit einer woche also
wieder lockdown feeling in deutschland
es geht wohl nicht anders bei den
infektionszahlen klar gibt es gewisse
widersprüche im lockdown konzept friseur
auf nagelstudio zu volle bahnen aber
leere kneipen unter anderem die
gastronomie ist seit montag geschlossen
schnell erzählt aber man kann es
natürlich auch immer wieder neu erzählen
ja normalerweise wäre einem sonnenschein
tag wie heute hier alles voll
stattdessen sind die freizügige statue
die cafés haben zu wir können uns das
mal anschauen es ist wirklich
menschenleer es gibt keine menschen die
herkommen zum brunchen gucken erst mal
runter meine erkennt so die straße gar
nicht wie die berger straße ist das
epizentrum des kneipenviertel sieht das
hier nicht seht also in der tat es sind
kaum menschen unterwegs da ist das
brauhaus zum schlüssel
wir sehen hier ist alles leer keine
gäste dürfen auch nicht hier sein
mitarbeiter sind natürlich auch nicht
hier ja natürlich nicht aber warum bist
du dann da wussten sie dass wenn kneipen
zu haben sitzen da gar keine leute mehr
verrückt ja auch medial macht sich hier
so langsam eine gewisse pandemie
erschöpfung breit infektions zahl steigt
er wert sinkt alles wichtig sicher aber
die leute wollen doch auch mal was
schönes oder nicht genau deswegen
interviewen verzweifelte
die reporter jetzt schon ernsthaft den
friseur von angela merkel
ich denke das kommt ganz normale gibt es
eigentlich um das nur die regeln
begründen wirklich zuzahlungen durch
alle drei bis fünf wochen lebt angela
merkel hier ein stückchen normalität
einem moment des frauseins momente des
frauseins jetzt in der neuen angela ich
möchte damit das klar ist im moment
wirklich kein politiker sein egal was du
machst irgendwer ist sauer
unsere kontakte müssen halt weniger
werden und das nicht ganz freiwillige
opfer bringen gastronomen und
kulturschaffende ist ganz klar eine
politische entscheidung wichtig ist nur
dass man die den bürgern dann nicht
verkauft ja wieso ein wellness produkt
jetzt geht es zuerst einmal um die
nationale kraftanstrengung im november
ein november der entschleunigung für uns
alle da fühle ich mich direkt
tiefenentspannt wenn man bedenkt wie
viele leute gerade unter akuter
existenzangst leiden hätte sich diese
formulierung allerdings auch sparen
können zwei miese wortspiele zum
preisverleihung bei der damen und herren
und noch mal
keiner hat eine bessere idee als kontakt
reduzierung was aber immer noch fehlt
leider ist eine ja ich nenne es jetzt
mal post seelenbrecher lock down
strategie oder soll das jetzt die
nächsten monate so weitergehen
jetzt im november ist lockdown die
infektionszahlen gehen runter deswegen
gibt es im dezember wahrscheinlich
wieder die üblichen büro
weihnachtsfeiern hier die beim zdf also
im januar leider wieder lockdown zahlen
gehen runter das wiederum bedeutet
grünes licht für après ski und dann
haben es geschafft im märz wird es
draußen wärmer adiós corona also sei
denn irgendwo in china fällt der nächste
flug und in den wok dann geht alles
wieder von vorne los also wenn es blöd
läuft andererseits im europäischen
vergleich kommen wir ja noch glimpflich
davon
überlegen sie mal in frankreich darf man
nur noch für eine stunde am tag an die
luft in tschechien waren wochenlange
alle schulen dicht und in belgien ist
man sogar staatlich zur monogamie
verurteilt in belgien müssen alle
geschäfte schließen auch darf man dort
nur einen knüppel kontakt haben
es wird das im flämischen landesteil
höchst amtlich genannt
verstehen sie bekannt aus der serie
knüppel kontakt in der city in belgien
sagt man auch nicht mehr prostituierte
sondern knüppel kontakt arbeiterin wie
gesagt im vergleich haben wir es noch
gut hier in deutschland unsere
gastronomen zum beispiel werden jetzt
für das ausgefallene november geschäft
entschädigt mal gucken was aus dem
weihnachtsgeschäft wird ständig heißt es
jetzt ihr müsst euch zusammenreißen
sonst gibt es kein weihnachten ja unsere
politiker haben sich regelrecht
festgebissen am ganzen thema weihnachten
motto wenn wir jetzt brav sind alle mann
dann kriegen wir zu weihnachten
vielleicht ein weihnachten vielleicht
aber es wird ein weihnachten unter
corona bedingungen seien aber es soll
kein weihnachten in einsamkeit sein hat
mich so gefreut auf einen weihnachten in
einsamkeit naja wir schalten wir live
nach berlin zu doktor alexander
wipprecht er leitet im kanzleramt den
krisenstab weihnachten retten herwig
recht warum diese fixierung der politik
auf die paar tage im dezember die paar
tage das fest der liebe sie gefühle oder
abgesägt entschuldigung
ja wir sind ja ein bisschen durch wir
haben doch sonst nichts was den bürger
versprechen können bald machen die
schulen wieder zu dann springen die
eltern reihenweise aus dem fenster ganze
branchen kneifen den arsch zu aber
weihnachten können wir retten
weihnachten das ist die motivation
karotte die wir den deutschen hinhalten
und zwar in jedem verdammten interview
wenn wir jetzt kämpfen wenn wir jetzt im
november gut durchhalten dass wir da ein
gutes weihnachtsfest feiern können dass
die advents und die weihnachtszeit eine
zeit wird wo wir wieder auch innerlich
am ende eines solch dramatischen jahre
zur ruhe kommen können wir wollen am
ende ein schönes gemeinsames
weihnachtsfest an schönen advent feiern
die menschen sich zu weihnachten in der
familie ordentlich treffen können und
dass wir diese wichtige zeit zum kraft
tanken und zur besinnung auch wirklich
nutzen können so das ist genau die
sinnlose gefühlsduselei die wir jetzt
brauchen advent kraft tanken besinnung
wenn überhaupt geht's weihnachten um
rotwein tanken und besinnungslosigkeit
eben nicht weihnachten endlich mal zeit
mit der familie also genau den leuten
mit denen man schon in den scheiß locker
und wochen eingesperrt war ich hey das
wird super fernsehen fressen dann wieder
fernsehen wunderbare weihnachtsklassiker
wie 3er o sohle für aschenbrödel oder
eine kleine land steckt sein opa an was
kann man dagegen weihnachten haben
ich habe gar nichts gegen weihnachten
ich hab was gegen der regierung die
keine langfristige corona strategie hat
und deswegen nur noch von weihnachten
redet wir machen so viel mehr
wir testen zum beispiel neue konzepte
wie risikogruppen mitfeiern können
adventskaffee geht zum beispiel auch
problemlos als video konferenz aus dem
pflegeheim das nach stehe gerade machen
wir denn tun aus als ich ihm
wir testen sogar spezielle schutzanzüge
mutti hat doch mal ein geschenk aus
kurz gesagt wir retten das fest wenn ihr
da draußen eigentlich mal zusammen reißt
ja gut dann feiern wir zusammen
weihnachten dadurch gehen die zahlen
wieder hoch und wie geht es dann weiter
das weiß ich noch nicht das ist sehen
wir dann ein krisenstab ostern dass ein
zimmer weiter
alexander wipprecht vielen dank
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da